als rocker bei den hells angels da war
er gefürchtet bis käfigkämpfer sah man
bei der manche neben mir selbst zum
gejagten wurde seine rocker brüder die
haben ihn nämlich für vogelfrei erklärt
und dann sogar auf ihn geschossen doch
jetzt gibt es in diesem wahnsinnigen
rockerkrieg eine spektakuläre wende
george an polos berichtet
was für eine wendung zwei wochen nach
den schüssen auf musiker sah man wie
jetzt diese rocker rolle rückwärts
plötzlich wollen sich anschlagsopfer sah
man und der mutmaßliche auftraggeber der
tat rogers oscar wieder ganz lieb haben
als ob nichts passiert wäre bild liegt
exklusiv ein dreiminütiges video von sah
man wie vor
köln 23 oktober 31 hells angels rocker
und boxer sah man ist auf dem weg nach
hause nur noch wenige meter von seiner
haustür entfernt plötzlich heizen
schüsse durch die luft
ehemalige hells angels rocker summer b
wurde opfer eines versuchten
mordanschlag
er ging hier die straße entlang als
plötzlich von einem schützen von der
gegenüberliegenden straßenseite
mindestens drei schüsse fielen da man
bespricht hinter einem parkenden pkw
entkommen zu dem kugelhagel die schüsse
verfehlen ihn knapp moki rocker sa mann
war zuvor jahrelang die rechte hand von
fatih k auch boxer und chef der hells
angels in köln ehrenfeld dem sogenannten
charter oder vier jahre lang arbeiteten
sie hand in hand sah man soll vatis
geldeintreiber und wichtigster
gefolgsmann bei illegalen geschäften
sein doch dann kommt es zum bruch der
rocker brüder sah man fühlt sich von
seinem chef partie ausgenutzt wirft dem
rocker boss öffentlich vor er reagiere
das theater oder vier diktatorisch in
seiner autorität angegriffen soll fatih
einen 15 köpfigen schlägertrupp auf
seine ehemalige rechte hand im charter
gehetzt haben sah man entkommt dem
angriff und veröffentlicht daraufhin ein
20 minütiges instagram video in dem ihr
vater droht beleidigt und vorführt
ich kenne dich ich war über zehn jahre
neben der tag und nacht ich hab so viel
über dich machen ich habe so viel
fundiert wenn ich einmal überdenken
würde würdest du nie wieder aus diesem
zelle aufkommen club habe ich geliebt
denn du hast mich und ehrenhaft mit
lügen daraus gekentert du hast angst in
dem sich jetzt gegen schauspiel
köln ist kurz vor einer revolution
du bist ein diktator
oder man löst sein hedge video zwar
bereits kurze zeit nach der
veröffentlichung
hochrangige hells angels mitglieder
sollen ihn nach bild informationen dazu
gedrängt haben doch rocker boss fatih
vergisst nicht er schmeißt den in
ungnade gefallenen sah man raus aus dem
bett standing opel frei doch jetzt die
große versöhnung mit hilfe eines
friedens ich das aus der türkei
[Musik]
wir sind seit 14 jahren freuen der mit
14 jahren sind brüder und bleibt auch
die nächsten jahre so ja was ich sehr
schade
ausschlagen
wir haben uns wieder lieben für die
kölner unterwelt ist diese versöhnung
sicherlich kein grund zur freude